well in just weeks President Trump is
set to meet face to face with North
Korean leader Kim jong-un and as both
sides ready for an historic meeting
concessions are already being made
correspondent Julian Turner reports
right now I think there's a lot of
reasons for optimism the Trump
administration is gearing up to face off
against dictator Kim jong-un in just a
few weeks the first time an American
president has agreed to meet with the
head of the North Korean regime South
and North Korean leaders plan to meet
this Friday to hammer out some ground
rules for the historic Trump Kim summit
in Washington's laser focused on the
outcome of this interim meeting even
some senior lawmakers are offering
advanced team advice it's been going on
for 25 years and obviously Kim jong-un
has learned about public relations and
is setting it up well for him Kim's
already announced some major concessions
over the weekend that in the past the
international community would have
deemed nearly impossible effective April
21st the North says it will cease
nuclear testing these launches of
intercontinental ballistic missiles
close a nuclear testing site as a
guarantee of transparency and Kim even
floated the possibility of releasing
three long held American hostages and
just today a brand new concession from
the South Koreans in return they've
silenced the towers of loudspeakers that
had continuously pumped anti North
messaging across the border for the past
two years the sound you hear well that's
South Korean music propaganda
essentially being blasted back into
North Korea North Korea right over my
shoulder the mountains in the distance
it's estimated that North Korea has
about 1500 artillery pieces positioned
in those mountains hidden all this is
adding up to what may be a major
diplomatic thaw that just a few weeks
ago seemed impossible administration
officials say right now president
Trump's focused on setting up
preconditions for Kim they say he wants
Kim to dismantle his nuclear program
before the u.s. commits to any sanctions
relief
keep in mind president Trump has many
points of contention with President
Obama's nuclear deal but his main
criticism has long been that the Obama
team missed an opportunity to demand
concessions from Iran before agreeing to
sit down across from them
at the negotiating table Bret Jillian
thank you